bonjour gérard haas merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
londres veut maintenant s'écarter de la
réglementation européenne concernant les
femmes cookies qu'est ce qui pose
problème exactement où aux britanniques
dans la réglementation européenne
alors déjà c'est une tentation avec le
braque site de
déréguler donc ça c'est la première le
premier objectif il considère en fait
qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie dans la
dans la politique des données que il y a
trop de consentement trop de
manipulations à faire et que en fait
finalement les petites entreprises ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne que
les grands donc ça c'est la première
cette tentative de la delà des les
rémunérations et de dérégulation qui
conduirait en fait le gouvernement et
notamment leur ministre de la culture a
à vouloir alléger la politique de
consentement de en matière de cookies
c'est un marché qui quand même colossal
et il faut dire que en même temps au
niveau européen on avait fait une
démarche d'adéquation et ç'avait été un
avantage considérable pour les
britanniques puisque ces derniers en
matière de messagerie en matière de
d'hébergement ou en matière de
communication bénéficier de coûts moins
élevés alors ça voudrait dire que là la
réponse qui pourrait être faite derrière
sa part l'europe c'est à dire que le
niveau d'adéquation les plus conformes
alors justement bruxelles lundi regardez
de de près cette nouvelle réglementation
oui mais est-ce que bruxelles aurait
tout simplement son mot à dire
mais oui il aura son mot à dire parce
que en fait on a on accepté en juin
dernier de placer si vous voulez les
transferts de données vis-à-vis du
royaume-uni au même niveau d'adéquation
il va y avoir si vous voulez la balance
des équipes ne va plus être respectée
puisque on n'aura pas les mêmes règles
et donc il ya un risque de concurrence
déloyale vous disiez tout à l'heure que
la grande bretagne a étudié cette loi
justement pour mettre sur un pied
d'égalité les petites et les moyennes
entreprises et les grandes entreprises
aussi si c'est ça si j'ai bien compris
mais c'est à dire que vous n'y en
angleterre il considère que les mises en
conformité aux règlements gère la
protection des données quelque chose de
trop lourd pour les petites entreprises
que ça freine l'innovation en fait il
faut pour faire passer en fait cette
possibilité d'être une sorte de paradis
si vous voulez pour les annonceurs donc
voilà et puis possède ce besoin de
dérégulation on le voit très bien
derrière ça
l'argument est faible parce que derrière
ça il faut quand même un niveau de
confiance dans l'univers numérique est
important et c'est ce que propose le
règlement général la protection des
données est ce que vous le veut
favoriser l'europe donc voyez on a
quelque part une démarche aujourd'hui
qui est d'attirer vers soir les
entreprises pour être hébergées en
angleterre alors est ce que cette
nouvelle législation pourrait peut-être
poser un problème dans les échanges des
données entre le royaume uni et les pays
de l'union européenne oui oui si jamais
en fait cette réglementation qui
révélera si vous voulez le nom des
bannières qui sont mises en place en
obtenir le consentement avait pour les
navigations effectivement il y aurait
une distorsion de concurrence une
concurrence déloyale et donc la halle
l'europe réagira évidemment elle réagira
et à ce moment là il n'y aura plus le
niveau de d'équations on a une
possibilité depuis d'une clause de
révision qui pourrait permettre si vous
voulez à l'europe de dire bah écoute et
voilà vous êtes en dehors des clous et
donc il n'y a plus la même adéquation
donc on peut pas faire de transfert sauf
à passer par des règles un peu plus
contraignant merci beaucoup gerra avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes avocat à la
cour d'appel de paris et spécialiste en
droit de la propriété intellectuelle
merci beaucoup